[Music]
in genetic surgery news whoa Chaddock
approach it is for real Gattaca Gattaca
yeah oh that's a great movie right I
love that movie that's the only time
Huma Thurman looks really hot and Ethan
Hawke was good as [ __ ] nuts and Jude
yeah and Jude Law Briganti within there
in the wheelchair yeah so it'd by China
number
Juwan okay one when they got their
accents all [ __ ] up oh it was a
Chinese scientist says he's the first to
successfully create genetically modified
baby babies what if they can make babies
that will never get cancer I mean I
think nature nature should take its
course the way damn my babies I pictured
a baby with the arm on his head like
this have you seen that Saturday Night
Live bit where that Rachel Dratch she
has that like yeah baby
yeah I thought it was like a glove with
a face like the Hamburger Helper logo if
you still go
that is the hamper if you're helpful oh
they better be if they wanted to keep
buying their products when was the last
time you bought that never but I
remember recently we talked about them
having a rap album like me I like this
whole I really did and Jake emu is a
long time ago I wasn't here no your it
was like Bobby Carozza
hand person memory Queen no I remember
you were playing eyeball right yeah what
was that movie Pan's Labyrinth
all rock I can't see
outside that was very creepy the
sciencism Shenzhen China
he claims like he used to human embryos
modified with gene editing this with
this technique called CRISPR CRI Joe
Rogan talks about that a lot
really yeah if you listen to his podcast
he talks about this technology all the
time I mean you using that same stories
over and over again it allows scientists
to make very precise changes to DNA and
so it's like surgery on DNA yeah Joe you
still have the interrupter it's like I'm
in a movie theater the guy next me I'm
like this is an important part of the
movie shut up you guys interrupted TIFF
right now I thought could be you I see
your straw set everything for you okay
so the whole thing that he did here is
that he used CRISPR to edit 16 embryos
and implanted 11 edited embryos into
ones of women and then so he was able to
have these two little Chinese girls
named Lulu and Nana boy well what's fine
a to Chinese in their name some days
yeah cute sounds like puppy names oh
okay so they're saying that he performed
gene surgery because the father is HIV
positive so they remove the certain dcgo
or they take this gene proven where they
were able to like close the door to HIV
that's amazing HIV I [ __ ] up large she
was like don't mess with my babies and
it's like wait what if we can get rid of
this well you know what it was you know
it was because it was coming out of
China China did some wild cheer I've yet
to hear and this is probably because of
the news that circulates everyone likes
drama so I'm only here in the dramatic
start oh yeah and they always do [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up and very selfish so as
soon as I heard that they were doing
this in China I'm like ah [ __ ] they want
green eyes and [ __ ] super soft skin
oh yeah give me big
anime eyes so that's why so I take a bag
you're right
so they're making aids babies not out
there d aging babies oh geez not too far
off no it's a slippery slope it's a
slippery so they're also giving them big
titties in there I'm not wrong let me
explain how you're not wrong so they're
saying here like the whole thing on like
experimenting like to actually creates
human life with edited embryos that's a
no-no like that's like unethical and it
is yeah so I got the call to who oh god
you're under Christian undergo medical
practice cultures so the pet it's wrong
it's just I think the UN handed though I
do that have been considered off limits
because it's a slippery slope what's
just slippery about it because I could
lead to designer babies like Kenny oh
okay okay like hot babies but what if
you grow hot people which is basically
what la is but that's fine nobody ever
thinks about that but they did it with
concern you could have Gucci babies
that's pretty cool so then they're
saying that this research hasn't been
published in the scientific journal and
it hasn't been vetted by other
scientists so many researchers in
bioethics are cautious about the claim
here but China gets to get to get to do
it all cuz they don't give a [ __ ] no the
University of your works with yeah I put
him on an unpaid leave mmm did it
regardless cuz he wasn't to note as he
announced it after like they didn't know
what did she get here the universe
they're not really that he didn't do it
at their place but wait so wait what
else did he do to them he did at his
apartment sounds like he did other labs
no it's because the thing is this is
what the vlog channel on watch this
watch on check it out hey man I'm just
doing some genetic surgery you know
there's a video explaining waited 16
ladies ready to take of being pregnancy
oh excuse me that's just post me that's
my lunch time do it no so right now he's
facing investigation by a local Medical
Ethics Board they're trying to see if he
broke any of Chinese laws or regulations
like what a lot of it yeah but they're
saying here like if the whole purpose
was to make sure that these girls didn't
get HIV there are other ways that are
already in practice that are ethical I'm
your line
it's called washing the sperm where they
like a child I just saw old grandma
[ __ ] scrubbing [ __ ] [ __ ] outside of
a budget underwear same weathered old
lady I saw a girl putting it in her
mouth yeah that's more open-minded
me John more traditional they pick out
the sperm that carry HIV and so they're
able to do so when new hat wouldn't hear
a guy with HIV and you bust nuts not all
of your nuts have HIV that's what I'm
playing
that's what they're playing here would I
understand from the way they it's a
question we'll let you don't know which
one has it that's what it seems like so
they can wash out the HIV already
exactly and then inject that into ladies
yes so that's already a way to avoid but
what if sperm washing is unethical in
China they like it dirty yeah we gotta
use other ways unnatural or some [ __ ]
CRISPR technology is it's like for so
many things though not just this so I
get more they're like well we already
have ways to avoid the HIV there's so
many other diseases or whatever you can
start regenerating organs and all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] ethics if you can
regenerate organs and with all that I'm
down yeah I want us to be able to make
more mistakes
me too I want to make another Steve
green that could do all kind of [ __ ] and
then I can that still live
now I don't want to do that other Steve
better than the Steve I'll kill them do
you get all the pleasure though and then
how we gonna know which one's the real
Steve yeah I'll be like this he's my
Steve so you I'm killing that Steve's
gonna be like wait but you're the fake
one it's a dude you have it all wet
I'm good at mafia you would not yeah you
don't know well yeah this do you guys
have like [ __ ] Steve oh it's me and I'll
be like oh god damnit these guys are
gonna kill me
I wonder if you clone them they'll have
the same memory that you have now cuz
then they still have to develop yeah
they definitely won't believe that
memory is like and they will have scars
Oh
things I have there yeah they're fresh
yeah yeah so it's almost like a baby but
like that's true think about it like in
civilization like the things that make
us unique if everyone has them then why
are we unique anymore look if everyone
has big dicks does anyone have a big
dick
no it's a standardized day but no one
everyone does no no if we grow people to
only have big dicks then you're gonna
have to have big [ __ ] to match that's
what I'm saying work like the design a
baby concept if all babies are fine then
everyone just back down ugly again right
so it's like what's the point because if
everyone has big dicks
there's gonna be a lot of hurt not
everyone can afford it anyway right oh
maybe that's what it is like there's
always gonna be low class people it's
like up here it's all hot beautiful
people with huge dicks and everyone's
got huge gigantic oxen and we still have
the Sentinel island natives that nobody
can go and they won't have beautiful
babies well maybe there aren't well they
better not do it because we paid for
twin girls so they're saying that by him
knocking out the ccr5 gene which is that
doorway to the ccr like the band cretins
right yeah great great
yes Clearwater do that is the widest
[ __ ] reference you could have ever
got it from your man my man he loved CCR
I only know one song what's the full
things new Clearwater Revival oh maybe
we can genetically modify babies so that
they hate Blues Traveler coming out so
that way we can get rid of Blues
Traveler
they aren't gone what you talking about
I like their lock-on yet how was that
cheesecake that the other night I heard
it I was like why the [ __ ] hey you know
what it's not that bad did they play the
middle and Shrek don't look it up I
think it's in there we got to look it up
later there's gene he knocked out there
saying that this will make the person
more susceptible for the West Nile virus
Wow
yeah yeah it's like he dumped the gun
cuz you never know what's gonna happen
to saying let nature take its course
oh that which one would you rather have
HIV or West Nile virus they both kind of
suck they really suck but then West Nile
I feel like we have
under control right yeah we'll just
leave it the way it is if I could design
a baby why why couldn't Matt why
shouldn't I be able to do that what I do
it at the [ __ ] I know how I am and I
don't want my baby to have the same [ __ ]
that I got yeah with your babies your
own thing and what should do you god
stupidity that's not genetic
oh yeah could be it could be like let's
say you're more prone to having like
your anger hormones and if you could
decrease that and you don't have anger
I'm what Steve are like I don't know
what the actual like code of law that
they're breaking that makes it right I
agree I think it feels wrong but I
believe I could have been born with a
stronger hairline that little guy
deserves a shot but then you never
realized like 20 years later something
else comes out wrong and he's like a
mutant so sort of go here what have you
now we asked genes cuz you just weak-ass
book and then you want your baby to be
strong and healthy yeah sometimes KC and
I talked about that too because you know
he suffers from his excellent thing and
like he's allergic to so many things and
we're like man hopefully here that's why
you hope your kids on a pan yeah these
guys are making my babies so you could
have like very very strong G yeah my
babies make stronger yeah yeah did you
know that's why I'm mixing she wants my
melanin he wants your invincible Mexican
jeans because Mexicans never get sick
yeah very rarely I get more sick than
Tiger does cuz he's got invincible
Mexican genes stuff for new he's very
now he's not broken yet yeah
[Music]